I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense we figured out once that men
would live five years longer without the
masculine role because if you just take
out of the statistics the deaths that
are due to danger speeding tension so I
always say to audiences of men you know
we can offer you more years of life who
else can do that and and it's why you
know there are you know men are
feminists too well I mean that's just
the truth there's masculine and feminine
in every woman and there's masculine and
feminine and every man and what it seems
like is happening is that there's a
there's I believe there's a shift to men
getting more in touch with that feminine
side of them and the woman of the
masculine right because the masculine
gets things done it goes and does it and
the feminine sits back and kind of we're
you know I mean how we're becoming human
I mean the whole idea of masculine and
feminine is invented I mean so how would
you describe certain energies then
certain human personally I really I
don't know I guess I would describe
their content nurturing patience I don't
know you know what whatever the the
quality is but I think sometimes I think
the whole world is divided into two
kinds of people those who divide
everything into two and those who don't
so I think it probably would be helpful
to at least adventure into not dividing
everything into two because we aren't
actually and and now and and transgender
and trance you know young people now who
are identifying
with a group they are not viewed as
being born into are very helpful you
know because it's beginning to do away
with those bipartite divisions do you
think it's somewhat a another another
division no like dividing the sections
up even more or is it just about
creating awareness that we're not all
like that we're not all one or this like
this or this well you know the first
step is probably rejection of the
existing divisions and then you try to
find yourself so I mean I I know what
you mean because I see you know on
campuses I see young men trans women who
are wearing things that I wouldn't wear
anymore if you know what I mean because
there's because they seem too feminine
but that's just part of the process of
change probably you know explore
exploring yeah explain how how how do
you how do you change the assumed
roles identity or just cultural
understanding of something like what
does that process look like and how long
do you think well I think we're seeing
it don't you I mean yeah you know I mean
and it you know I'm Way older than you
so I just want to say in my life you
were supposed to wear skirts and frilly
things and you know just the fact that
that we wore pants when I was growing up
was the rebellion that we didn't wear
lipstick I don't know was a rude that we
didn't wear high heels was a people made
endless fun of women's asses and pants
and when I was growing up because they
were not supposed to wear it so it's
it's and men were supposed to be super
macho in my neighborhood and all of that
so it's it's a it's a process
[Music]